be there Ian what's going on how are you
sorry about that douche I mean you know
I got it you there's there's only one
Ian to go around I guess huh I was
actually doing my podcast when I got all
the texts they want to cut short like
interview and yeah okay all right so let
me get to it here the Honda inside a
rapport with with Ian Rapoport first one
first up here
the Broncos hiring Vic Fangio does that
mean that dick Gary Kubiak's can run the
offense Ian it means Gary Kubiak will be
heavily involved in the offense he'll
either be offensive coordinator or he
will be senior offensive assistant
helping out a lot and that's you know I
think that's something that that's
something that they would like that
something they always kind of had in her
head you know but look I mean Gary
Kubiak has wanted to come back down as
an OC or senior offensive assistant he's
never gonna be a head coach again his
wife will never let him and if you have
Vic Fangio maybe the best defensive
coordinator the NFL one in the defense
and running the show it's doing some
toughness and they have Gary Kubiak
running the offense that's a lot to like
right there and Kubiak Kubiak when he
ran the offense in Baltimore was
terrific
with with Flacco so is that something we
can draw points A to B as well they're
in well they already do have a stop-gap
quarterback already in the building with
Case Keenum you know they could they
could move on from him it would
capitalize it would sting a little it's
not like it would be crushing and then
bringing on another band-aid I mean it's
possible but I wouldn't say it's likely
I do think that they'll be able to get
the most out of case came who I'm almost
positive Kubiak also had in system the
least he knows a man is familiar with
them but then I do expect them to go out
and draft to be as well all right a few
quick hitters then here what's the
dolphin search looking like right now
they're gonna interview Darren rizzi on
Friday and so it doesn't seem like they
have anything anything imminent they'll
plus a lot of the really good candidates
Flores Christmas cards are still in the
playoffs so they're kind of they're kind
of slow
playing this a little bit it's possible
that uh that they're talking to
Baltimore just to see what the hell Mary
and how much it would cost them for John
Harbaugh or is that the done deal in
Balltown uh I think it's going to be a
done deal from my understanding in
Baltimore with Harbaugh now maybe Miami
is waiting to see just to make sure in
case it falls apart I think that's
possible
they're clearly in no rush nor should
they be because everyone's you know
everyone's playing in the playoffs
I know Vienna had some interest I never
got the sense it would really work with
Harbaugh what's the Bengal search look
looking like in rap record what's going
on there nothing imminent there though
it does seem like they are done
interviewing dance Joseph I know did a
really nice job these are familiar with
the Brown family had someone who's
getting strong consideration that Taylor
would be Rams QB coach similar situation
had a great interview young but I know
they really liked him and then Eric the
enemy also very much in the mix path
yeah the enemies in the mix there is he
in the mix with the Jets what is a jet
search looking like right now the Jets
are my understanding are choosing
between McCarthy obviously formers
Packer packers coach former bucks
Osito bumpkin Adam GaSe and then that
rule D Baylor's coach that's kind of
their guys better stoah mm-hmm okay any
timeframe on this sort of stuff I was
told the jet I was sort of waiting for
it last night because never done
interviewing and I was told don't hold
your breath it's not going to be
imminent and then I had someone else
tell me who could find out by the end of
the week but you know what these
timeframe is to get accelerated the
Packers were gonna do second rounds of
interviews and then they interviewed
battle for four three hours in the side
of the hiram things could always be in
force a little bit and and how did the
Browns come upon Freddie kitchens we all
obviously know what what what he did
attached to the hip with Baker Mayfield
but to go from never having call to play
until the fourth preseason game in his
career to now running the entire
operation
walked me through all that and the
Browns fans wondering if he has the the
wherewithal to run the entire operation
in I think the better question is why
did anyone else interview I mean all
these first time coordinators who don't
have his resume are getting jobs
like why wasn't he interviewed by other
people I mean he came in he he's been a
running backs coach he's in a tight ends
coach he's been the quarterbacks coach
to help resurrect Carson Palmer's help
resurrect Carson Palmer's career and you
know then he comes in and transforms the
Browns like why did anyone else take a
look at him
I think he's ready he's fantastic and
brilliant and hilarious and you haven't
won as a guest you will see he's a great
guy and I think the Browns are
interesting good things well your two
statements there before I let you go
because it sounds like somebody's
calling you on the other line is that
your first statement made it seem like
why didn't anybody else contact him like
he's not potentially head coaching
material but then your second statement
said that he is so what answer your own
first question then it's tough for me to
know I honestly I've thought about this
a lot of talk to other GM's about this a
lot it is possible that Freddie kitchens
didn't get head coach consideration
because there's almost like a head coach
I mean I have no idea but it's literally
the only thing I can come up with
because he looks like the guy that was
waiting for the Bud Light case to open
up with their first win of the season is
that what you're saying yeah that's the
guy and and I don't know but remember I
mean everybody wants to win the press
conference you I mean I don't know what
else could it be
he's not a self-promoter doesn't play
the maybe a game I get that
but what else could it be okay and then
the last thing for you ian is who's the
guy that was uh that we would be
surprised that was reached out to that
said no from what you hear as far as
head coach yes head coaching interview
from either college or from the
retirement community that was reached
out to and said no III can't come out of
retirement I won't come out of
retirement or I'm not coming out of
college I would say well I would say the
mad camel from Iowa State turned on the
Jets was probably most interesting one
of those can only wanted to Cleveland
job and I don't think we've seen the
last of that campbell who uh you know
not a big-time name but so Nate done a
really nice job and surely could end up
in the NFL someday
Ian thanks for the time appreciate it
we'll chat site that seen rapport at rap
sheet
that's the Honda insider report the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience